[Music]
blank doctor had seen a great deal of
death in his time it was the very nature
of the work he devoted his life to
patients were lost on the operating
table or taken from him soldiers fell on
the battlefield right before his eyes
even The Simple Touch of his hand could
stop a person's heart he had watched the
world outside turn to hell as the sun
destroyed every living thing that
wandered into its beings of a cursed
light but somehow even after all that he
had witnessed this latest loss weighed
heavy on his heart he hadn't known
Ferdinand well or worked with him for
very long but he had offered comfort and
support in a time when all seen lost the
giant man had been steadfast loyal and
dedicated to the cause so devoted in
fact that he gave his very life for it
it was ferdinand's choice to go that way
to roll the dice and risk his body for
the sake of the doctor's work he knew
that and yet the pain pressed down on
him like a dark ocean uncharted waters
that threat to drown the doctor in a
grief he had never felt before he knew
that the work was waiting he could hear
the cries of the fleshy creatures oozing
by outside waiting to be cured of their
ailment still he could not pull himself
out from beneath the blanket of deep
depression that weighed him down all he
could do was lie in his bed a cot
formally reserved for d-class prisoners
staring up at the ceiling and feeling
the minutes ticked by eventually it all
began to blur together with no need to
eat drink or even sleep there was
nothing to break up the passage of time
doctor the plague doctor lifted his head
for the first time in a long time at the
sound of a voice coming from the doorway
there stood Lord Blackwood the Dapper
gentleman's sea slug his Rhino pores
twitched curiously as he slithered into
the room hello my friend the doctor's
side I say I've been a bit worried about
you old job Lord Blackwood said we
haven't seen you in quite some time not
since the untimely lost of our dear
comrade food and I confess I'm finding
it hard to carry on does it not seem
hopeless to continue the fight against
the forces out there how could I be so
arrogant to think I could do battle with
the sun itself the plague doctor rested
his head in his gloved hands Balderdash
Lord Blackwood shouted the doctor looked
up at him startled forgive my Outburst
old sport but that is the grief speaking
through you as intelligent men we must
honor our feelings as they are parts of
us but they cannot be our rulers as the
great poet William Ernest Henley once
wrote it matters not how straight the
gate how charged with punishments the
scroll I am the master of my fate I am
the captain of my soul stirring words
and yet the doctor trailed off and yet
what Lord Blackwood seemed to swell with
emotion we find ourselves in dire times
yes but what are we to do in the face of
them roll over show our bellies and
embrace defeat not I sir never I I don't
believe you should either would Fernand
have wanted you to let yourself be lost
this way the plague doctor sat with that
thought for a moment then solemnly he
shook his head no he wouldn't then we
shall rally pick yourself up come with
me and in the memory of our fallen
friend we will sing a happy tune as he
would have we mourn we celebrate his
life and then as we always have we do
what needs to be done come with me
doctor the sea slug led the way and
though he still felt the call of the
Void tugging at his heels the doctor
followed dimly he could hear Lord black
would ask are you familiar with the
works of Gilbert and Sullivan the plank
doctor was not in fact familiar with
them so he could not not join in as Lord
Blackwood attempted to lead him in a
chorus of I am the very model of a
modern major general still The Sound of
Music of any kind of Joyful Noise lifted
his spirits just the same the two spent
several hours together swapping old
stories singing songs and remembering
Ferdinand The Lovable Cannibal at one
point Lord Blackwood brought out a
Tankard of Home brewed ale he had been
working on in one of the empty
Laboratories it smelled strange and
tasted stranger but it was still nice to
share a drink with a companion after so
much hardship eventually Lord Blackwood
passed out flopped over on his side and
snored softly the doctor leaned against
the wall nearby resting his eyes for the
first time in many many days it wasn't
happiness not quite but it was a kind of
peace and a welcome reprieve from the
torturous thoughts that had gripped him
as of late but the peace did not last as
the doctor began to hear sounds from
within the tunnel the passage that led
somewhere deep beneath the foundation's
site he could hear footsteps muffled
voices creeping ever closer they did not
sound like the fleshy monster who had
invaded the facility before but he could
not be certain if they were friend or
phone he scrambled to his feet preparing
to defend himself if necessary not
Blackwood he hissed attempting to Rouse
his sleeping friend but the slug
continued to snooze away if the need to
retreat arose he would have to use
something to scoop up the sleeping Slug
and carry him to safety the plague
doctor was just picking up a nearby
bucket when the first of his unexpected
visitors emerge from the darkness it
appeared to be an ordinary human man
wrapped in dark robes that covered his
face his arms were left bare and glinted
in the low light they appeared to be
made of metal but the doctor did not
recognize the kind he removed his robes
to reveal a deeply tanned face black
hair and piercing blue eyes there was an
Arcane symbol carved into the man's
forehead just above the Gaze that now
fell on the plague doctor a beat of
silence passed between the two men
before the doctor finally spoke up
please sir identify yourself the strange
man stared at him curiously not quite
knowing what to make of him my name is
Kane and who are you he asked I am a
doctor he answered simply how did you
find this place I had some help had this
cane glanced over his shoulder to unseen
companions waiting in the shadows it is
safe here you can come out as the plague
doctor watched three more figures emerge
from the tunnel first a man wearing a
kind of light blocking hazmat suit he
removed the suit slowly exposing blonde
hair green eyes a tattered brightly
colored t-shirt and cargo shorts the man
that followed just behind him was
wearing a similar suit and removed it to
reveal a lab coat and an unusual
necklace hanging around his neck the
final visitor was not a man at all but a
large mass of slime at first the plague
doctor felt a shock of anxiety but at a
Second Glance he recognized the slimy
creature it was
999 the friendly being that often roamed
the halls of this very site it cooed
excitedly at the sight of the doctor
though it knew not to touch him it
pseudopods wiggled in a gesture
resembling a wave hello yes hello my
friend the play doctor smiled but who
are the rest of you his eyes settled on
the amulet around the third man's neck
he had seen it somewhere before ah Dr
bright I presume I'm afraid I did not
recognize you with this new face Dr
bright green broadly yep it's me little
apocalypse can't keep Dr bright down
good to see you again doctor this is
scp-507 he gestured to the blonde man ah
you can call me guy he stuck out of hand
to shake but the doctor shook his head
it would be best if I did not but it is
a pleasure to make your acquaintance and
you've already met scp-073 Kane Dr
bright nodded to the man with the metal
arms of course this little guy needs no
introduction he patted scp-9999 which
wrapped its pseudopods around his hand
and gave it a friendly squeeze I had him
with me at site 17 for some cross
testing when everything went to hell
good thing too never needed an emotional
support slime more in my life Dr bright
was in a room near mine when the alarms
began to sound Kane explained as soon as
it became clear something truly
disastrous was happening we were
retreated underground with as many
supplies and survivors as we could and
where were you the plague doctor asked
guy uh I was out of town the guy grinned
at his own joke I popped into a forest
Dimension like the Amazon but it went on
forever that was beautiful but the
mosquitoes were the size of my head and
I couldn't wait to get back when I did
though everyone was gone nothing but the
alarms going off over and over and over
again luckily this guy he patted Kane on
the back found me before those uh melty
things outside did uh those who have
succumbed to the sun sickness I know
them well the plague doctor's face fell
we lost a member of our party to them
not long ago I am sorry for loss Cain
said and his face made it clear that he
really meant it we have supplies if
you'll need them he pulled a small cart
from the tunnel generator's food clean
water weapons would happy to share in
exchange for shelter here I thought we
agreed I was the leader Dr bright pipped
up there are no leaders in a time like
this only survivors Kane said solemnly
but you got to walk at the front Dr
bright pouted thank you all of you the
plague doctor's heart swelled with
gratitude at the gesture at the
knowledge that there were still allies
in this nightmarish World doctor are we
having company Lord Blackwood awoke
behind him yes my friend it appears we
are the next few weeks passed
comfortably almost joyfully a far cry
from the grave fog of sadness that had
lingered in the aftermath of ferdinand's
passing as CP 999 guy Kane and Dr bright
brought new life into the facility
lighting it up both figuratively and
literally with the help of the
generators they had brought Dr bright
had plants to set up additional power
sources and devoted his time to
experimenting with anomalous materials
he had managed to recover from Storage
he also offered his services to the
plague doctor as a new assistant someone
to help him find a cure for the plague
that raged on outside their Wongs Kane
promised to make Supply runs insisting
that his metal limbs made him less
vulnerable to the effects of the deadly
light's beings he still covered his skin
with thick robes whenever he went
outside however I'm not sure if it would
take me or not but that is not the
chance I'm willing to take he had sand
meanwhile guy entertained the group by
reciting the plots of his favorite
movies TV shows and Comics he had joined
Lord Blackwood as one of the de facto
storytellers of their new little band of
survivors perhaps the plague doctor
thought they would find some kind of
Happiness here perhaps things really
would be alright after all meanwhile out
in the nightmare Escape beneath the
transformed Sun a wicked mask was
wandering the land in search of a new
host its artificial body had begun to
corrode to rust and Decay beneath the
torrent of black sludge always pouring
from its mouth and eyes soon it would
not be able to Pilot the structure
anymore and would find itself trapped
again waiting for an unsuspecting person
to come along and put it on in this
current climate the odds of a human
happening upon the mask were lower than
ever and though it would never admit
this out loud the mask was beginning to
get a little bit nervous perhaps it
should head back to the site try to make
nice with the plague doctor and see if
he would offer some assistance no that
would be pathetic seeking help from
someone so low so wretched it would
manage fine all on its own still as its
rickety mannequin legs creaked cracking
and splitting apart with every step The
Mask knew it had to move fast and think
even faster if only he could find a
weapon some kind of Leverage they could
return to the site and force the doctor
to become its next host as the mask
pondered its options its gaze fell upon
one of the fleshy beasts oozing across
the ground in search of more people to
pull into its molten embrace the
creatures ignored the mask for the most
part knowing it was inorganic and
impossible to convert but the masks
suddenly thought could it perhaps
convert one of them would its
Consciousness be strong enough to
override the hive mind the monsters all
seem to share the mask had overcome the
will of kings of heroes and villains
alike surely it could take one of those
simple lumps of Goo the flesh creature
moved slowly a little bit at a time it
had all the time in the world the mask
supposed or at least it believed it did
as The Masks snuck up behind the
creature its expression changed from a
frown to a nasty smile it reached up
toward itself angling just right it
would have to land perfectly for this to
work but it knew it could stick The
Landing anywhere on the thing should
work after all it didn't have a face for
this particular Beast time had run out
and it was time for the ask to take its
body for a spin then it would pay a
visit to its old Nemesis back at the
site the plague doctor was having an
intense discussion with Dr bright about
all that each man had witnessed so far
Dr Wright listened with Fascination as
the plague doctor described his attempt
to treat one of the infected humans the
invasion of the massive flesh bees that
had taken the human survivors right
before his eyes and fernand's Noble
sacrifice to save their shelter from
destruction Dr bright in turn told of
his own trials the difficulty getting
into the tunnels the retrieval of guy
before he was lured outside by the
creatures and his mission to rescue as
much research as possible before setting
out to find a safe place to hide sadly
it seemed that the SCP Foundation knew
even less about how to counter the
effects of the Sun than the plague
doctor did still two heads were always
better than one and an extra set of
hands to help with the work would
certainly speed the process along for
the first time since her Ferdinand was
lost the doctor felt some kind of hope
all we need to do now the plague doctor
said is procure another test subject
this will of course be rather difficult
as it is perilous to venture outside
perhaps we could appoint some manner of
the task force Dr bright nodded oh we
could try that Gaines done pretty well
going out there so far maybe he can
bring us back something next time he
goes out for supplies the plague doctor
opened his mouth to agree but before he
could say another word he heard
something knocking against the window
this particular window had been treated
to filter out the deadly light some time
ago seemingly by accident but the
foundation was making the glass
resistant to other forms of attack
through its tinted glass the doctor
could make out a strikingly familiar
face the porcelain mask with the
permanent smile staring in at him hello
doctor The Mask laughed black slime
pouring from its mouth with a gurgling
sound villain the plague doctor spat
what do you want from me why must you
assume I want something from you perhaps
I've just come by to pay you a friendly
visit the mask's voice was smug gloating
because you sir are no friend of mine
the plague doctor crossed his arms
defensively oh you have guests I see Dr
bright I'm surprised you made it this
far the mass cackled at the side of the
man should have known you've made it
I've heard cockroaches can survive
anything Dr bright shot back have you
come here to trade verbal blows the
plague doctor asked or with a true
purpose in mind why doctor I came here
to visit you and to show you something
wonderful though it was impossible the
mask's grin seemed to widen what could
you possibly have to show me the plague
doctor was growing irritated tired of
the masks games my new body of course oh
silly me you can't see it when I stand
this close let me just back away and
give you a better look with a horrible
squelching sound the mask's face
retreated from the window before the
doctors could even stop to ask one
another what it might be the terrifying
answer was right in front of their faces
the mask was not piloting an ordinary
bipedal host but rather had positioned
itself somehow on top of a massive mound
of gelatinous Flesh it was one of the
enormous beasts that had previously
tried to invade through the tunnel the
amalgamation of dozens of melted people
stuck together into a revolting ball of
molten skin bone and muscle do you like
it the mask asked I've been building it
for days it started small you see just
one person though I could scarcely call
it one anymore so walked and pathetic
sad I could just cry the mass flickered
to a frowning face just for a moment and
then the smile was back but I won't it
was so easy to drop myself right onto
the thing and before I knew it I had a
lovely new vessel so malleable so
indestructible and so very easy to
expand so simple to just it flexed one
of its tentacles snatch up anything I
see pull it out into the light and let
it become a part of me not that anything
had a choice you're a monster Dr bright
exclaimed yes isn't it marvelous the
mass tossed its head back with a cackle
and I haven't even told you the best
part yet I'm not finished growing you
see I need more always more and you too
in whatever sad silly little creatures
you have in there with you will make the
perfect addition I've been waiting for
the opportune moment and I think now is
a perfect time don't you agree you'll be
waiting a long time Dr bright said we
will never go outside devil the plague
doctor added that is perfectly fine
gentlemen perfectly fine I'll just come
to you The Mask leaned backed and with
all of its might through its massive
body against the wall with a crash the
building shook with the impact rattling
from the blow can it break through Dr
bright asked why died I'm afraid I
cannot say for certain the plague doctor
said solemnly these monsters they're
unlike anything I have ever studied
before same Dr bright grimaced all the
while the mass continued its assault on
their hiding place as he collided with
the wall again and again the two doctors
heard a sound that made their stomach
drop the sound of something splintering
apart it was working the wall was
beginning to give way Dr bright the
plague doctor cried we must Retreat do
you know the same place to which we can
flee I think I just might Dr Wright
nodded quickly gather the others we have
no time to waste Dr Brighton the plague
doctor assembled the rest of their
ragtag group Kane was engaged in a
lengthy conversation with guy while
scp-999 played with a wind-up toy car it
had found Lord Blackwood was Brewing
another batch of his unusual ale they
were all shocked at the news of the
sudden Invasion but as fast as they
could they gathered their supplies a few
weapons and the remaining generators
then they headed back into the tunnels
but not before Kane made one final
defensive move using his anomalous
strength he dragged an enormous steel
cabinet in front of the entrance
blocking it from view if the mask did
break in hopefully it would not be able
to see where they had gone then together
they left the Little slice of
familiarity they had carved out in this
frightening new world and set off into
the unknown now go check out when
daybreaks scp-049 and scp-001 can
scp-049 finally cure when day breaks for
the first two parts of this epic Tale